THE STATE OF EUROPE:
Once upon a time, Europe
was the most domineering force in the entire
world. They controlled swathes of land across
the entire globe extracting resources, manpower,
and wealth for their own prosperity. Since then,
Europe’s outdated and predatory system
of colonialism and imperialism has been
replaced by capitalism which is ironically also
rather predatory. And for the longest time,
it seemed that Europe was thriving in this new
world order. They had dozens of heavy weights
in the Fortune 500 in the pharmaceutical, banking,
energy, and fashion industries. But, there is one
industry in which Europe has completely dropped
the ball in: tech. Despite being some of the most
modern and powerful countries in the world, Europe
only has 2 tech companies in the Fortune 100,
companies that you probably never even heard
of of: ASML and SAP. And while ASML and SAP
are no doubt champions in their own right,
put next to American big tech champions,
they pale in comparison. ASML currently stands
at a $272 billion market cap while SAP stands
at a $181 billion market cap. For perspective,
there have been days that Apple has lost SAP’s
entire market cap in a singular day. And that’s
just comparing the top players. If we go down the
list, it looks even worse for Europe. Europe’s
8th largest tech company doesn’t even make the
Fortune 500 list, and the only globally relevant
European tech startup that immediately comes to
mind is Spotify. Now, I can already hear
some of you saying that this is actually
a good thing. It’s a good thing that Europe’s
economy isn’t dominated by dozens of big tech
monpolistic corporations. And I definitely get
where you’re coming from, but at the same time,
this is very much a massive disadvantage for
Europe as they’re starting be viewed as the second
world when it comes to tech. So, how did Europe
get left so far behind when it comes to tech?
THE DISPARITY VISUALIZED:
Now, it’s easy to be apathetic
to big tech companies. Boo hoo, Europe doesn’t
have any mega tech companies that control every
aspect of our lives. But, one of the positives of
big tech is that they’ve created millions of high
paying jobs; however, this doesn’t seem to have
really affected Europe nearly as much. In fact,
when it comes to compensation, European tech
workers are only earning about half as much as
American tech workers for the same jobs. Take
entry level software engineers for example. In
the top American tech cities, we’re talking
about 128 in San Francisco and 133 in NYC.
In the top European tech cities, however, we’re
talking about 63 in London and 60 in Amsterdam.
And this disparity goes all the way to the top.
For director of engineering, we’re talking about
202 in San Francisco and 174 in NYC, but for
the same job, it’s only 124 in London and 101
in Amsterdam. And let’s not forget, it’s not
like London is cheap to live in. If anything,
London is a tier 2 city in terms of cost of living
for which tech generally pays 15% less but not 50%
less. You might be saying that that’s because
Europe doesn’t have ultra rich tech companies
that can pay as much and you’re right. But, almost
every American tech company has a European base
and they’re now using Europe as a cheap labor
market. And I’m not even talking about Eastern
European countries like Poland and Ukraine. I’m
actually talking about top cities like London.
Take Facebook, for example. For level 5 engineers,
the pay average compensation of $421,000. You
wanna guess how much they pay L5 engineers in
London though? Well, for the most part, they
pay something in the low $200s. Some London L5
engineers even earn as little as the $130s. Now,
I’m not saying that you should feel bad for any
of these people. All of these people are obviously
extremely well off whether they’re making $400
or $200 or $130, but putting aside the specific
numbers, think about it from a macro scale.
Imagine you’re the United Kingdom. For centuries,
you ruled the entire world. People used to
say that the sun never set on the British
empire. You’re not as powerful as you once used
to be but you’re still a world power. After all,
you still have the 6th largest GDP in the world
coming in at $3 trillion. But despite all of that,
America has the audacity to come into your country
and pay your citizens half the compensation or
less. I don’t know about you but if I was the UK,
I’d feel pretty insulted, but it gets even worse.
You see, European tech not only compares poorly
to America but it also compares poorly to the
developing world. Take Google India for example.
Google generally pays slightly less than Facebook,
like 5% or so. But, you wanna guess how much
L5 Google engineers are making in India. Well,
a lot them are earning high $100s. Aka, the
top 25% of Indian FAANG engineers are making
more than the bottom 25% of European FAANG
engineers. And that isn't meant as a hit
against India. If anything, it’s actually the
exact opposite. All this shows is that India
is very much heading the direction of becoming
a first world country while Europe is heading
in the exact opposite direction all because
of tech. And that’s just looking at the UK,
one of the most prosperous European countries.
So, Europe as whole compares even less favorably
to the modern tech industry which brings us to the
question of what in the world happened to Europe?
EUROPEAN CULTURE:
Researching for this video,
I was hoping to find some sort pivotal event that
completely changed the trajectories of American
tech and European tech but there was no such
singular event. Rather, it seems that the current
state of European tech is very much a culmination
of decades of evolving European culture. You see,
Europeans tend to be more practical. They
actually want to live life and not just
live to work and this ideology has been worked
into their laws themselves. America is the only
advanced economy that does not guarantee
paid time off. All EU countries, however,
mandate that employers provide atleast 20 paid
vacation days every year. And many countries like
France actually mandate 30 paid vacation days or
6 weeks per year. And all of that is in addition
to paid public holidays and usually unlimited
sick days. What this means is that American tech
workers only get about 2-3 weeks of vacation time
while European tech owrkers usually get 7-8 weeks
of vacation time. But, the amount of vacation
time Americans get doesn’t even matter because
Americans just don’t take vacations. Many tech
companies like Netflix actually offer unlimited
paid time off because they’re extremely confident
that their employees won't abuse it. In fact,
the average American with unlimited PTO only
takes 10 days or 2 weeks off per year. Europeans
on the other hand actually tend to use all of
their vacation time. In France for example,
it’s common to take off all of August. And
that’s just vacation time. On a weekly basis,
Europeans tend to work 35 to 40 hours while
Americans tend to 40 to 45 hours. And if you look
at the more competitive Americans and places like
India and China, it’s actually more like 70 to 80
hours. Now, studies have shown that the European
approach produces more productivity per hour, but
in terms of overall productivity, American tech
workers generally come out far ahead of European
tech workers simply because they work 500 to a
1000 hours more per year. As such, tech companies
are unsurprisingly willing to also pay American
engineers a lot more than European engineers. But
actual productivity only tells half the story. The
other half is due to vastly different compensation
laws and policies especially when it comes to
benefits. In America, on top of your cash salary,
you can usually expect a bonus, up to a 3% match
on a 401K plan, and discounted health insurance.
In Europe, however, you can usually expect a
bonus, up to a 10% contribution to a pension fund,
and fully paid for private health insurance.
In general, Europeans tend to get far more
small benefits here and there and that’s just
what’s apparant on the compensation package.
Behind the scenes, European employers have to
pay far more in taxes. Take social security
tax for example. American employers only have
to 7.65% in social security tax. In the UK,
employers have to pay 13.8%. In Germany, employers
have to pay 20%. And in France, employers have to
pay a whopping 45%. Obviously, companies are going
to take all of this into account when making job
offers to Europeans leading to far less upfront
compensation. So, all of that kind of explains the
quantitative side of lower European compensation,
but the reality is that the biggest factor leading
to Europe being left behind actually has
nothing to do with objective reasoning.
CONTENTMENT:
It’s easy to write off the European
tech industry using some sort of quantitative
measure whether it’s European’s working less or
higher taxes or more benefits or whatever the
case may be. But, the reality is that there is
only one reason why the disparity between American
tech and European tech is so large. It’s because
Europe has something that America never had and
likely never will: contentment. Whether its on a
macro scale where big tech companies are trying
to grow to billions of users or on a micro scale
where employees are vying for the next promotion
or bonus, Europeans often just don’t care,
atleast not nearly as much as Americans. Take
employee tenure for example. The median employee
tenure in America is 4.8 years while the median
employee tenure in Europe is over double at 9.8
years. This is primarily because Europeans are far
less likely to constantly jump around companies
looking for the best compensation and title
possible. And this isn’t to say that Europeans
aim low. They absolutely do want a solid income,
healthy benefits, and a comfortable retirement.
But that’s also all they want. They’re not looking
for the mega millions that American tech workers
are after, and likely the best example of this
is stock based compensation. You know how we were
talking about European tech workers only being
paid half of American tech workers? Well, that’s
only if you look at total compensation. If you’re
just comparing cash salary and bonus, European
tech compensation is actually quite comparable
to American tech compensation espeically when you
factor in more paid time off, larger retirement
contributions, and better health insurance. Where
European compensation actually falls way behind
is stock based compensation. Let’s go back to our
American L5 Facebook engineer for example. Out
of their total comp of $421,000, a $183,000 or
nearly half is just stock. In London, however,
these same engineers are often paid as little
as $20 to $30k in stock, or only about 15% as much
as their American counterparts. This isn’t because
big tech is snubbing these employees but largely
because Europeans tend to value stock compensation
far less than Americans. In America, especially
with startups, engineers are often willing to
forgo their entire cash compensation or take a
very modest salary in exchange for more equity.
In Europe, however, it’s the exact opposite. Most
would much rather have a consistent and reliable
cash income instead of equity. And when you take
the most lucrative part of tech compensation out
of the equation, well, European compensation
is what you’re left with and the higher you go
in title, the bigger the disparity. European L7
Facebook engineers for example are earning up to
half a million dollars less. And honestly, I don’t
see this changing as this isn’t just the case with
tech but basically every industry. US doctors
average over 300 while many European doctors
don’t even cross 100. US lawyers can ofteen cross
200 while European lawyers often don’t cross 100.
It’s this same trend is carrying over to the tech
industry as well just at a different level. And
given that the Europeans that do want to earn
more money and start big companies just come to
America, it’s likely that this disparity will
only grow with time. But hey, maybe that’s not
such a bad thing. Europeans may not be home to
the highest salaries or the biggest companies,
but they are home to the happiest people on
the planet, and in the end, isn’t that what
really matters? With historically high interest
rates, the appeal bills and bonds is the higher
than ever, yet traditional brokerages haven’t
really adapted with the times. They still expect
people to use clunky bond tables, scroll through
long overwhleming lists, and even use virtual
keyboards till recently. And that’s why we created
our own modern bond platform: Silo. At Silo,
we prioritize the user experience and the ease of
finding and investing in the issuers you know and
trust, so that you too can lock in high yields.
Also, choosing a strong user experience doesn’t
mean sacrificing on safety. Every Silo account
is insured by $500,000 in SIPC insurance and
$2.5 million in FDIC insurance. Also, all funds
deposited on the platform will be maintained by
our trusted custodian, Interactive Brokers, who
has experience managing $373 billion worth of
assets over the past 45 years. So, if you’re
looking for a modern way to invest in bonds,
please consider checking out Silo in the
description below. Someone else that’s getting
left behind by the tech industry is the American
middle class. Check out this video to learn more.